the concluding chapter of the Metal Gear
Solid saga Metal Gear Solid 4 guns of
the Patriots
so Metal Gear Solid 4 it takes place
five years after Metal Gear Solid 2 and
as snake says in the intro war has
changed and it's completely changed its
completely controlled by the Patriots
ultimately there's something called the
war economy which the Patriots control
they have these little proxy wars that
break out because they dictate these
proxy wars have to break out here here
and here and the financial result of
these proxy wars is that the economy is
balanced how the Patriots deem it should
be balanced the weapons are controlled
the soldiers have nanobots in their
bodies which can be controlled to an
extent it's like the world is under this
passive-aggressive fist it doesn't even
know it's under and so now it's been
learned where liquid Ocelot is liquid
Ocelot is revolver ocelot who's now
mentally liquid snake as I showed middle
your solid to that was happening so
Solid Snake's been hired to take out
liquid Ocelot I'm going to delve into
the plot a little bit later on but right
now we're going to talk about the
controls because the controls in Metal
Gear Solid four are so much different
than the other Metal Gear Solid games up
to this point at least Metal Gear Solid
4 unlike the other Metal Gear Solid
games really goes on a trigger systems
like l1 is aim r1 is your action button
r1 also you can like put them in a
headlock l1 and r1 really do most
everything you need to do in the game in
terms of action and upon that being
different the thing that people griped
about most of Metal Gear Solid 4 is it
relies less on stealth and I gotta admit
it really does there are five chapters
or scenarios in this game three of the
five have stealth but even then its
stealth in the middle of a war zone like
in the first mission you're dropped in
the middle of this war zone these two
sides are fighting Otacon calls you and
he's like alright snake there's no need
to fight anybody they're doing their own
thing these are not your enemies you are
not their enemy do not fight them just
sneak around this guy saw me he's like
is the enemy start shooting me I was
like well you couldn't have been more
wrong in that assessment there Otto Kahn
Thanks so you know you just blow the
guys away it's done I'm just saying when
you see a battlefield you don't think Oh
sneak around it you think alright let's
get the guns and start shooting dudes
the first two missions in this game
you're sneaking with a bunch of soldiers
who are fighting that in this game has a
[ __ ] ton of weapons you have more
weapons and Metal Gear Solid 4 than one
two and three combine so the game's
telling you alright sneak around by the
way here's a [ __ ] ton of weapons that
you're not going to use because you need
to sneak you know it's stealth its
tactical
let's be a knowledge action but use the
guns you know you want to and I do want
to and I did so does the game
concentrate less on stealth yes it does
another thing this game has a lot of our
cutscenes this is thing that people hate
it to they're like oh my god the game is
half cutscenes it does seem like that
and there are hours upon hours of
cutscenes in this game that being said
I'm fine with it because it's the
concluding chapter of this entire saga I
want the story to be told to its fullest
don't leave [ __ ] out bring on the
cutscenes I would rather have a two-hour
cutscene at the end of this game than a
five-minute cutscene which I have to
choose one of three colors I'm being
honest and you know I'm right Metal Gear
Solid 4 I will say gives you the answers
you've wanted for a couple games now
well the whole liquid Ocelot thing don't
worry they got it covered which is funny
because you know the liquid Ocelot thing
the way liquid snake is an ocelot body
it's explained a certain way into and
explained a little bit as an easter egg
in three then in four they explain it a
completely different way this is the
subject of a lot of conversation a lot
of controversy that has no real
resolution you can see it as the
explanation in for completely negates
two and three or you can see it as two
and three did happen then the way they
described it in four happen whatever you
want to see go for it I hate seeing
things in a way that negates other games
so I see it as oh it happened that way
in - and the way it was explained in
three is you know legit and then it
happened the way it happened in four
this is me talking in code this is me
trying not to spoil it for you it all
happens but you find out who the
Patriots are in this game who the
Patriots were who the real bad guy was
back in the day that started all this
[ __ ] but I gotta say mission four is the
biggest nostalgia bomb ever I'll say
it's a nostalgia bomb in the sense that
if you played Metal Gear Solid 1 ten
years ago this is how this this mission
is so nostalgic and relevant if you
haven't played Metal Gear Solid 1 ten
years ago and you haven't played Metal
Gear Solid 4 yet you haven't been into
the game for the past decade it's not
like I'm gonna just crush ten years of
anticipation for you so yeah I'm gonna
let you know what it is in mission for
you go back to Shadow Moses Island from
Metal Gear Solid 1 and I'm telling you
it blows your mind the only way I can
accurately describe it is imagine you go
back to the house you grew up in you
walk in there's still dust on the
furniture and [ __ ] but everything is
arranged the same I'm telling you it's
trippy it's awesome I love the fact that
they brought you back to Shadow Moses
Island and you go across certain
territory and you hear audio flashbacks
and you're like holy crap
it's just the biggest nostalgia bomb
I've seen in a game ever period in my
life and the flashbacks don't start at
the Shadow Moses incident I mean there
are things that people will say and
you'll see the little X icon in the
corner of the screen you push the X
button a bunch of times you'll see
flashbacks come on the screen the whole
game is really one big nostalgia bomb
wrapped in some exciting gameplay
wrapped in some really sweet
storytelling with less stealth
admittedly and of course if you're going
to make a character of badass make
riding a badass ridin is so awesome and
Metal Gear Solid 4 remember Metal Gear
Solid 2 people like me were like dude
what a bait-and-switch who's this guy
Metal Gear Solid 4 he is the new cyborg
ninja and the dude just owns ass in this
game there are these geckos which are
ultimately like a Metal Gear Rex design
type thing these things will kick the
[ __ ] out of you you just run when you
see him when you get a rocket launcher
you end up assessing yeah I could spend
three rockets killing this thing or I
could still run and you do riding just
takes them out with this sword dude this
dude is dude he's business
I am lightning the rain transformed just
a side note only badasses get to say
things like that and have it work and he
says it and it works I'm glad they made
riding relevant and I'm glad to see his
resolution also this game has some sweet
resolution when the game is wrapping up
I don't know whose story I love most but
I will say when you see ridings it will
become clear why I don't even want
anything to do with Metal Gear Rising no
need to send that guy out into the
battlefield man he did his part and it's
not just him so many characters in this
game have sacrificed so much to get this
job done I mean people have lied to
people they've loved people have lost
people they've loved some people have
ruined the reputation some people just
won't stop you see Solid Snake he looks
like an 80 year old man in this game it
only takes place five years after -
because and again little spoiler this
isn't the thing here what's gonna make
you go what you told me that snakes
ultimately a weapon the weapon has an
expiration date so he's prematurely
aging and he's gonna die soon so he
needs to get this job done and that
really helps and you go in dude give up
man it's okay you know that scene in
Dark Knight Rises where Catwoman looks
at Batman she's like you don't owe these
people anymore you've given them
everything
Batman's like not cute it's like that in
this game do snake is in such bad shape
by the end of this game hes hacking he's
crawling to his destination you're like
to just
Wow I don't think I've seen such
determination in a game character ever
in my life and snakes still professors
on ne'er Oh
never was never will be and that's what
makes him a complete hero I love it when
heroes of luck I'm not a hero just a guy
with an obligation and we've all thought
to ourselves ok Metal Gear RAY was
designed to fight other metal gears so
who would win in a fight Metal Gear rare
Metal Gear Rex you want to know play
Metal Gear Solid 4 so Metal Gear Solid 4
guns of the Patriots is the most
action-packed of the Metal Gear Solid
games that relies more on action less on
stealth but it does have the stealth
element in it but it's more or less
there for the story the game exists to
give you resolution with the characters
to wrap up its epic there's a scene
where it's all coming to a head and
there are three things going down you
see three different split screens one
with snake one with ride and one with
just a bunch of other [ __ ] happening
people are dying people are getting shot
snakes crawling you're like man you
don't really get that a lot of times in
games good when the director and creator
of a saga knows like alright this is an
epic it needs to end epically it's heavy
on the cutscenes but ultimately I have
no problem with it at all Metal Gear
Solid 4 guns of the Patriots is a
fulfilling ending to one of the best
sagas you're gonna find in games and is
completely awesome tacular
my favorite in terms of gameplay and
story is Metal Gear Solid 3 the fact
that Metal Gear Solid 4 wrapped up in
such a really good and fulfilling way
and gave me everything I wanted in this
game and more got to give it props so
your favorite conclusion - your favorite
epic what would it be
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more